-I want to thank my guests,
Hilary, Larry, and Josh Meyers;
and Frank Carter
and the 8G Band.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
I want to thank all of you
for being with us
on this special night.
Everyone at home who took time
to be with us.
I want to thank our crew
for working so hard
all year long
and our writing staff
for working so hard.
I want to thank my wife
for getting
Thanksgiving dinner ready.
Also, the video with the kids,
my wife wrangled that.
That was not easy to do.
I know it looked good,
but she did a lot of wrangling,
getting them
into those costumes,
so, I want to thank her
for that as well.
And I want to thank her
incredible family, my in-laws --
my sister-in-law,
my brother-in-law --
everyone who's getting dinner
ready for us.
And we really do appreciate it.
Stay safe.
Get vaccinated.
Get boosted.
We love you, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]